google decommissions deepmind's health
app jurgen schmidhuber leads an ai
initiative in saudi arabia and i have a
new paper welcome to ml news
hey hey you yes you
do you run experiments
machine learning experiments
yes
how do you track them
what
that's not a good way to track them oh
hell no here's what you should do you
should use weights and biases
coincidentally this video is sponsored
by them what is it it's a system to
track your experiments track your
artifacts reproduce all the things
you've ever done see metrics data sets
models from the inception of your idea
to the final deployment and beyond
this is the ultimate tool you can get
started with just one line of code yes
one line of code and be amazed at what
it gives you hyper parameter tuning
metrics tracking resource utilization
model and data set versioning on cloud
and on-premise get this and much more
when you sign up to weights and biases
personal accounts are completely free
what are you waiting for sign up now no
actually watch the video first then sign
up or sign up now and sign up later get
your mom to sign up get your pet to sign
up there's absolutely no reason not to
go to this url and get your account now
cheers
[Music]
hello and welcome to ml news on this
beautiful glorious monday let's dive
into the first story techcrunch writes
google confirms it's pulling the plug on
streams it's uk clinician support app so
this app has a bit of a history since
2015 deepmind started it up originally
trying to bring more ai into the health
ecosystem now the streams health app
isn't actually an ai focused app it's
kind of an app to track health data and
assist clinicians in making decisions
the goal was always to bring ai into the
picture but this apparently has never
succeeded the article details the
history of the app as it went through
deepmind stages then of course the big
scandal where it was discovered that
deepmind didn't really have the legal
basis for dealing with the data that
they were dealing with that was a weird
sentence and finally deepmind handing
over the app to google health even
though they said they would never share
anything about this with google and now
finally google deciding to turn off the
app completely whether or not this is a
result of data privacy issues or just
being a result of the business case not
being strong enough we don't exactly
know so if you're interested in this
this article on techcrunch dives fairly
deeply into the issue what is special is
how often it is mentioned that the data
is going to be deleted so it starts off
with at least two paragraphs saying the
data is going to be deleted it mentions
it throughout and then it ends again
with a paragraph on how the data is
going to be deleted so rest assured the
data is going to be deleted i'm winking
you can't see it i'm winking
now the article is also a little bit
critical of google starting up projects
and then killing them off after a short
while such as google plus or the many
many many many
many many messaging apps that google has
released things like google video and so
on but honestly i think this strategy
has worked out so far we got a couple of
very nice products out of google that
started exactly like this that we might
have never gotten if every single new
product is an eternal commitment to
support it that being said bring back
the free storage for google photos this
was actually useful so finally google is
turning off this streams app there's
apparently still one group of customers
that is using it ongoing i guess they'll
have to come to some sort of an
agreement until the end of their
contract but going further let's just
wait for the next google inventions
there should be like some sort of a
betting market where you can bet whether
or not new google products will make it
five years past their inception could be
fun
ifls writes ai makes strangely accurate
predictions from blurry medical scans
alarming researchers so this is an
article about this paper right here
reading race ai recognizes patients
racial identity and medical images that
is a study into various data sets and
algorithms and whether or not they can
detect a patient's race just from
radiological images such as these ones
now there is a common pattern among
articles like this one that usually some
confounding variable wasn't taken into
account like source of data set or
things like this however this paper
specifically pays a lot of attention to
eliminate all such confounding variables
and really tests multiple hypotheses on
how the model makes its assessment so
there are apparently a few distinct
markers of race even in these
radiological images but even if they
control for those the models are still
able to make out patients self-reported
races the really interesting thing is
that even if the images are degraded
such as this one right here and really
pixelated the models are still able to
make out the patient's self-reported
race with a higher than random accuracy
but the pictures themselves would be
completely undiagnosable for any human
and certainly humans couldn't make out
the race of the patients so as i said
the paper is a fairly lengthy
investigation into these models and data
sets including trying to tease out race
from models that have been trained not
on predicting race which essentially
means that in order to predict some
health outcome the models in some part
make predictions that correlate with
race and it is a fairly lengthy article
but if you're interested in these things
definitely give it a read it seems like
to be a very thorough study of these
things but the article here frames it
all in terms of how terrible this is how
biased these algorithms are and well
there's certainly truth to that and many
of these algorithms are in fact bias
when they shouldn't be and due to
various reasons there also is the
apparently rather shocking conclusions
that your health outcomes interact with
your genetics i know new concept so
again while we can certainly all agree
that results like this are worrisome and
there are problems with bias in a.i it
seems that people would like their
ideologies to overrule reality and i
don't think that's a worthwhile goal so
that all being said these problems are
of course incredibly difficult but we
should look at them with the view of
what's going to help the most people and
what's going to deliver the best
outcomes for all individuals and there
are probably no easy solutions for
incredibly interconnected problems that
are extremely multifactorial and include
things like genetics environment society
data gathering and the entire historical
context of all of that and that i guess
is my rather boring take on that
in related news the new york times
writes facebook apologizes after ai puts
primates label on video of black men
facebook called it an unacceptable error
the company has struggled with other
issues related to race now the article
is about this daily mail video about a
couple of black men and the algorithm
asks keep seeing videos about primates
yes or dismiss so the classification
algorithm made a mistake here and this
is not a new thing as the article states
in 2015 google mistakenly labeled
pictures of black people as gorillas and
the article also said more than two
years later wired found that google's
solution was to censor the word gorilla
from searches while also blocking chimp
chimpanzee and monkey the article then
goes into some more inter-company things
inside of facebook trying to link this
to the system or something like this
which i find quite shady honestly these
systems have a number of issues there
are issues of course with data
collection there are issues with all
kinds of other stuff but ultimately
these systems are trained in a way that
errors are errors so if you fail to
distinguish a yacht from a sailboat that
is an error to the model in the same way
as if you fail to distinguish a human
from a primate the model has no inherent
way of knowing that one is a socially
acceptable error and one is a totally
socially inacceptable error there are
ways to mitigate this but they usually
require efforts on the part of humans
that go there and essentially correct
for all the potential socially terrible
errors that the model can do and very
often that burden is so large it's
combinatorically very very hard to do
this all you can do is just block entire
pieces of the search space in order to
mitigate these mistakes this is
displayed as some kind of like a
negative system like well the ai is
still biased but now we're just sort of
censoring it yes i mean what can you do
it's very easy to complain about these
types of things now of course many of
you might have noticed that technically
the model isn't wrong as human are the
most abundant and widespread species of
primates but you know technicalities
aside i think we can all agree that this
isn't an output that you would want from
your system so what's the solution i
don't know probably the best solution
would be an attack from multiple sides
where the companies invest more work
into mitigating these types of errors
which means essentially collecting more
training data on these intersections of
very socially critical issues such that
the models get more confident about them
and on the other hand it might also
require a little bit of a rethinking in
society where we see a mistake like this
not as some terrible thing happening but
more into the category of mislabeling a
sailboat as a yacht and vice versa it'd
be nice if we get to a point where we
think ah cool the system made a mistake
let's go on with my life but of course
it's not always that easy because we use
these types of systems in situations
where it actually matters what the
system predicts so ultimately it comes
down to close supervision of your
products and continuously evaluating
their deployments again it's a hard
problem i'm confident we can make
progress on it complaining about it is
fine just complaining and acting like
it's the most terrible thing and it
means something beyond what it actually
means is probably not helpful
ml news is previously reported that this
still is taking a break due to the high
load and the very high quality standards
they have leading to kind of volunteer
burnout they released what appears to be
some of the last articles that they're
going to release in a while and they are
on graph neural networks one is a gentle
introduction to graph neural networks
the other one is understanding
convolutions on graphs so the article
pretty much contain what their title
says if you're interested in graph
neural network i can absolutely
recommend you give these articles a read
they have very good illustrations of
what's happening examples and as you are
used to from distilled articles their
quality is extremely high can definitely
recommend check it out
jurgen schmidt hoover announces that
he'll be starting as a director of the
kaust ai initiative kaust is the king
abdullah university of science and
technology in saudi arabia and is one of
the most well-funded universities on the
planet schmidt hooper will remain in all
his other positions and lead the ai
initiative there apparently traveling
back and forth and on his blog he writes
we hope the new ai initiative will
contribute to a new golden age for
science analogous to the islamic golden
age that started over a millennium ago
so quite likely we'll be hearing a lot
more from kaust in the near future
not really ml related but maybe a little
bit if you care about codex and models
that produce code github has submitted a
friend of the court brief which is
essentially an advisory letter to the
courts on dmca takedown notices of
copyrighted material in the space of
programming specifically the brief
concerns what they say is claims
involving non-literal copying of
software and they give an example case
right here where the sas institute has
brought infringement claims against
world programming software and
specifically they claim that it is not
specific lines of code that the
defendant has copied but only that other
aspects like the code's overall
structure and organization were used the
blog post here also says after examining
the first question the court found sas
institute simply repeated and repeated
that their system was creative but did
not point to any specific examples that
would enable the court or the defendant
to identify which parts were used in
order to ultimately define those parts
that were actually protected by
copyright the court ruled for the
defendant leading to this appeal imagine
something like you didn't exactly copy
my picture but you use the same
organization of putting paint on the
canvas now get a live sas now of course
i don't know all the behinds like
copyright is such a complicated issue
and there are legitimate cases where
people steal from each other and i can
even see that there are some cases where
you can say well the structure of my
code is so unique and creative and they
copied it or something like this like
can't you just spend the money on
something useful so github's position on
this is that with a dmca takedown notice
the noticer should specify in as much
detail as possible what are the parts of
the defendant's work that are infringing
on the copyright such that there is even
a possibility of responding apparently
it's totally possible to issue a dmca
takedown notice simply by saying well
there's something in there and i agree
that's not helpful but ultimately
helpfulness and what ultimately results
from the legal system and the courts
don't always match so we'll keep an eye
open on how this develops
so this week there wasn't really many
questions in the news to be answered but
there were some really nice questions on
reddit some really good threads i
thought at least going with it so there
was a thread on how machine learning
will revolutionize physics simulations
in games this is almost like a blog
article in a reddit post seems a little
bit wasted honestly but it's pretty cool
it details what kind of models exist for
doing physics simulations and what their
advantages and disadvantages are for
example here is one that's specifically
good at modeling large deformations and
tears and so on this is a piece of bread
tearing apart and it also details how
machine learning is being used in order
to speed up these simulations
essentially what you want to do is you
want to run the simulations which are
very intensive until you have a data set
and then you want to train the model to
sort of predict the end of the
simulation from the beginning which
seems like it should be impossible but
hey it's deep learning so so pretty cool
if you're interested in the intersection
of deep learning and physics give the
reddit post a read and of course an
upvote so good job syed hm for
contributing to the ml subreddit
aristocratic octopus asks what are the
most important problems in ml today and
i specifically want to highlight this
thread because the answers are both
diverse and really good they range from
diverse environment learning
catastrophic forgetting modular learning
unstructured data causality view shot
learning generalization and so on now
these are things that are researched
today yet i think if you are coming into
this field and looking for something to
do you don't really have an idea of what
to work on this thread might be a little
bit of inspiration for you kamwa asks do
you reproduce a method for
state-of-the-art comparison or do you
just take the result from the paper of
the method for state-of-the-art
comparison it's an interesting question
i've seen people doing both but the user
says for example they try to reproduce a
method yet they couldn't get the exact
same score saying they only got a 30
accuracy on a task but the paper claimed
they can obtain a 70 accuracy they say
they just ran the author's code with
maybe a little modification some authors
said that they need to tune the hyper
parameters and they also say they spend
almost 90 time just trying to reproduce
previous methods welcome to ml research
that is yeah i don't know what the
answer is here there are also various
opinions in the comments you can almost
guarantee that a lot of these research
papers nowadays you cannot really count
on their numbers they might leave away
from the paper a lot of tricks that they
have done to reach that number or the
numbers are just fake altogether of
course it could also be that the code
they have on github is kind of old code
which happens often if you resubmit
somewhere you redo some experiments
something changes in the meantime so
there can be legit and illegitimate
reasons why you don't get the numbers
you do what you can do is you can report
both the number they have in the paper
you can also report the number that you
achieved with their method and simply
consider this as two different bass
lines and explain yourself in the paper
it is a problem that you spend like
ginormous amounts of time reproducing
bass lines and as the phd progressed i
more and more moved away from trying to
get the exact numbers that baselines
have gotten and simply give it my best
shot at reproducing them and then
reporting that i think it's up to you as
long as you detail in the paper what you
do at least you can't be faulted and
lastly ollie macp asks what kind of
hyperparameter optimization
do you use and again if you are looking
for good advice this thread might be
something nice for you there are
suggestions such as ray tune of tuna
hyperopt and so on if you want a cheap
method i would start with all the hyper
parameters on the default setting then
simply take the one you think is most
important and vary it a little bit while
keeping the others constant then once
you've found a good setting for that one
keep that one constant and vary one of
the other ones while also keeping the
other one constant if you found a good
setting for that one keep going one by
one through the parameters until you've
tuned all of them once then start from
the beginning and at some point you'll
converge you might get into a loop but
it's kind of unlikely that usually got
me to relatively good places in
hyperparameter search and it takes way
less compute than running some kind of
big grid search usually these hyper
parameters aren't that dependent on each
other so tuning them individually is
okay
speaking of tuning and reproducing and
performances there is a new paper from
hciusi and supsi called the devil is in
the detail simple tricks to improve
systematic generalization of
transformers which gives a number of
hints to what you might want to tune
when you train transformers so the paper
is an in-depth investigation into what
it takes to train transformers and what
matters and they give some advice for
example relative positional embeddings
seem to outperform absolute positional
embeddings for certain tasks also you
should be careful on how you do early
stopping and how you scale your
embeddings among other things and lastly
the paper highlights the trouble with
only having iid validation splits and
not some sort of test that measures
generalization capabilities beyond the
exact distribution that the model was
trained on if this is of interest to you
give it a read
also a collaboration between apple and
the vector institute release
unconstrained scene generation with
locally conditioned radiance fields at
iccv 2021 releasing code on github as
well and this is pretty cool so this is
scene generation but with a freely
moving camera so apparently previous
works have sort of focused on small
camera movements which is already
impressive but with this technique it
allows you to generate scenes from a
generator so this is essentially a gan
that first creates a latent floor map
and then based on that floor map
generates the 3d environment in which
you can then move around the camera
freely so essentially you can render
that scene from wherever you want it
still looks a little bit wonky but i
think the possibilities of these
techniques to make it into entertainment
into training into simulation into
gaming is pretty cool and probably not
that far away again the code is on
github check it out
facebook ai research open source's
common objects in 3d a large scale data
set for 3d reconstruction so this is a
data set for 3d reconstructing what they
call common objects apparently this is a
crowdsourced data set of objects that
people just apparently happen to come
across which is pretty cool because
these are things that actually appear in
real life seems like an extremely
challenging data set but often the most
challenging data sets spur new types of
discoveries if you work in 3d
reconstruction this might be your next
challenge
salesforce releases warp drive extremely
fast reinforcement learning on an nvidia
gpu we've seen a number of libraries
recently such as brax and isaac gym that
make reinforcement learning a lot faster
by making use of the accelerators warp
drive is especially geared to do
multi-agent reinforcement learning so
multi-agent reinforcement learning is
where you have many agents in the same
world and they need to interact with
each other somehow cooperating or
competing and the difficult part is of
course that you need to evaluate
strategies for all of them they depend
on each other and things like back
propagation become extremely hard
especially if you're limited in compute
power this library makes optimal use of
the power that you have and i can
definitely recommend that you check it
out if you are not a giant corporation
speaking of giant corporations and
reinforcement learning there's a new
paper called boosting search engines
with interactive agents and look it's me
so i've worked on this with this team as
part of my internships and consultancy
gigs at google but i am in no way the
main author here the paper is about
developing agents that search in more
than one step so if you go to a search
engine usually you enter some sort of
query and if you don't immediately find
what you're looking for you might look
at the top results and then kind of
refine your query to find better results
and that's exactly what we try to do
with agents here so here you might start
off with who won the us open you'll see
a bunch of sports appearing and you
might rephrase saying that you're
specifically interested in tennis and so
on until you achieve the answer that you
want what's specifically cool about this
is that there's code to go along with it
so next to the specific code that powers
these search agents there is a
implementation of mu0 based on a library
called seed rl now this is also geared
at making optimal use of your
accelerators in such as a gpu or tpu
while massively distributing the
inference environments so the mu0
algorithm is generic i have authored
part of it and if you are looking to use
mu0 this might be a good implementation
for you as the mu0 paper as well as the
pseudo code they released contain
various small subtle errors that
nevertheless make the whole thing
essentially not work this implementation
right here to the best of my knowledge
contains less bugs and it works pretty
much with gym environments so you plug
in a gym environment with a little bit
of extra information on how your tensors
are shaped and so on and that's all you
have to do to trigger mew zero so check
out paper check out code and let us know
if something's wrong
and last news ai startups claim to
detect depression from speech but juries
out on their accuracy this is from
venturebeat now time and time again we
see these articles about claims that ai
can do something but it turns out the
reality is a little bit more complicated
so there are a lot of examples of
systems claiming to detect something to
do with covid and then it turns out none
of them is useful this here is a little
bit less bad because with kovidge there
was a big academic push to just make use
of the hype to get papers published here
we're already a little bit into the
direction of actual products being
implemented but still the article
details numerous problems that startups
face some have only collected their data
from certain parts of the world to be
exact just from one city others focus on
only native english speaker and confuse
not being able to speak english with
showing signs of depression still others
neglect entire accents even for native
speakers and the list of problems goes
on and on and on again i don't think
this is a problem where there is any
kind of easy solution i'm strongly of
the opinion that we need to make
progress in this there is a shortage of
mental health professionals and it's not
inconceivable that machines can assist
us and can deliver better lives to
people even in the mental health area
but exactly what shape that's going to
take and exactly how we're going to
prevent some sort of dystopian future
where some sort of buggy algorithm has
way too much power over your life is i
guess one of the big challenges of our
generation again a good place to start
is to continuously monitor and evaluate
the systems there are and to allow
ourselves to take some risk as we push
forward as long as we have it under
control again i know not a super strong
opinion but what can i do i'm boring
cool this was it for ml news thank you
so much for watching listening and
subscribing if you know someone who's
not informed about the world of ml
please tell them about ml news we're
about to reach 100k subscribers very
exciting i'll see you next time bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]